policiers et pas d'éducation
c'est normal à dati les radios comme
skyrock n'apprendront jamais le
patriotisme et l'amour de la nation
pendant longtemps
[Applaudissements]
la france a son histoire c'est mon rôle
à jouer faire réfléchir et mon devoir
même banni par la gloire ouais je
m'appelle karim
j'aime la france et son décor mes prises
de position ont valu de jolis menaces de
mort j'apporte une importance
particulière métaphore libre de dire ce
que je pense je me tâte taylor disque
d'or
mon pays est malade jetant la
température restant loin des caricatures
jeu soigner ses plaies s'est fracturé
rappeur algérien est fier d'être
français
à cause de mes pensées et anti savent
qu'ils sont prêts à me défoncer
né à la dass marianne m'a appris le
respect la tolérance de vivre ensemble
hamon elle m'a donné la paix gosses de
la rue
c'est le site d'arak emporté ma mère vos
petits rappeurs de merde pour les
cahiers d'endormis par de l'herbe hilton
après ça tu en dis moi tu t'attendais à
quoi
ils ont mangé fargo nos gosses en
racontant n'importe quoi
je me sers de mon micro comme un porte
voix tient avec mon pied du mur fut ma
confiance est fortement dessinons un
nouveau monde
bâtissons à chaque seconde servons-nous
dépassé comme une leçon d'espoir
succombe elle se banaliser des faits
divers pour diviser
ça pousse à la révolte ça chante la
haine sur un air de gratte
j'ai le regard vide le coeur ensanglanté
je reste pro face à leur haine à l'image
de ce policier plaques
j'ai pas envie de perdre rentrer dans le
troupeau jeux peuvent chacun des mots en
défendant mes propos sur le même radeau
sur le même bateau unis fier sous ce
même drapeau
j'ai pas envie de perdre y rentrer dans
le propos je pèse mes mots en défendant
les propos sur un même radeau sur un
même bateau unis fief sous un même
drapeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chaotique 747 de son vrai nom
karine bouchard lourd et c'est un
rappeur niçois de 38 ans qui est faux de
l'agglo a connue pour être pro forcé en
font du rab ouvertement cessera firth
est rentré dans des clichés et vendre de
la merde à nos gamins à leur faire
croire que la ville il a sorti un des
femmes dénudées j'en passe il ya eu la
drogue flic génération lorsque ces
producteurs la responsabilité que ces
médias prennent leur responsabilité
aujourd'hui on a tout un pays à
reconstruire il faut pas attendre des
prochaines présidentielles pour le
construire
il faut reconstruire maintenant dans
l'amour et l'unité collet souhaite vous
[Musique]